what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so to be honest with you guys I'm not
the most experienced person when it
comes to anime a lot of us because
honestly I never really knew where to
start when I was a kid I used to watch
Dragonball you know because I always
thought Dragonball was a really good kid
show was really fun to watch you know
heroes fight you know characters fight
different things like that but I never
really knew where to start after that I
mean I knew that there were anime is out
there you know like those you know
Gundam and different things like that
but you know it was almost like jumping
into you know sixty years were the
comics without having any idea where to
start and so it's kind of ironic you
know because being a person who's read
comics for 20 years I could tell you
almost anywhere to start if you want to
pick up with a certain character
assuming that I know you know my
knowledge what about that character
whereas with anime I'm just a lost ball
in high weeds and it's funny to me
because when I look at anime and again
this is from an outside a guys on the
outside looking in so bear with me if my
ignorance of anime comes to bear in this
video but from the outside looking in it
always seemed to me that anime was more
of this sort of existential discussion
on like how a person views the world and
their place in the world and all that
kind of stuff and all these emotions go
into it and different things like that
I've seen animes which are really weird
where it's like a person will take a
bite of food and it's like the super you
know dramatic like I'm eating this food
you know and they'll get so amped up I
don't know if that's part of the whole
anime culture or not but you know for me
it's always kind of intriguing because
with a Batman anime show oh my god I
guess is a movie dude it looks so beast
it looks so amazing
I am so hyped about this it looks so
awesome because it looks like it's
basically bridging this amazing gap like
like Batman as a character over the
years has had some character exploration
but for the most part almost everything
about Batman is basically just this guy
who's essentially just a human who
dresses as a bat he's really smart he's
got some martial art skills he fights a
bad guys in the days saved there are
some great stories that come in between
like nightfall for example was an answer
to the question what happens if Batman
fails and then you have some really cool
iconic stories like neo the long
Halloween which is sort of this post
crisis on Infinite Earths retelling of
the origin story of two-face there's a
lot of cool things that go into like the
Batman mythos so on and so forth but for
me he was largely just kind of the same
guy that he always was he's just a guy
who dresses in a bat suit and beats up
criminals in the middle of the night
honesty if you want to read some of the
best storytelling when it comes to
Batman read something called world's
greatest superheroes Batman's war on
crime it looks amazing and it is
incredible
well told it's written by Paul Dini the
guy who spearheaded the Batman the
Animated Series show so it's not totally
obscure in terms of the writer but it
really is a good story it's pretty
amazing I remember if I cover that or
not regardless for me looking at this it
looks awesome because I know that when
it comes to early from what I understand
when it comes to anime anime I think is
steeped in like Japanese culture which
is to say you know a lot of the
honorable things that people do and the
kind of honorable battles and honorable
warfare you know and die in honorable
death I'm not I'm not gonna swear to
that you know by any means that's
probably one of those in one of those
instances where my ignorance of anime is
showing but again it's cool to me
because I love the character of Batman I
think it's intriguing but when you take
that character and you throw it into an
anime style a movie or show or however
it is it's gonna appear it becomes
something interesting because instead of
just getting a joker who pops up and
just does some goofy things right where
he's like today I'm going to copyright
fish you know you get this really cool
sort of inspiration based off of I would
say Scott Snyder's run on Batman those
the guys who are familiar with that and
most everybody is by now but for the new
folks who were coming from the anime
community and are not really familiar
with scott Snyder's run on on the Joker
for years and years and years the Joker
was just kind of this goofball character
and a lot of that goes all the way back
to the 1950s with you know the the
college code Authority different things
like that but with the new 52 when
Batman was relaunched the Joker was dark
I mean he was sadistic he had had his
own face cut off and then just kind of
strung it up on his head I mean it was
it was dark I mean there was one scene
there's one moment where he basically
subdues Batman and the rest of the bat
family and when they wake up they're
sitting in the Batcave and they're
looking at these plates when the Joker
takes his hops off and it's their own
faces on the plate so the implications
of the Joker remove their faces because
their heads are bandaged and everything
it's really dark and it's really really
sadistic and twisted but to me that that
reflects the nature of the Joker and you
know from from my experience of the
anime looking at the idea that it's more
like okay moving beyond what this
character does like what's the core
nature of this character The Joker
represents chaos in the absence of law
and order then let's translate that into
him and then let's just high end like
anime themes I have no real idea what to
expect but from what I've seen just from
the trailer alone it looks like it's
gonna be insane plus if I'm if I'm if if
I'm correct and what I've seen like
we're gonna see things like like
Deathstroke
we're gonna see Damian Wayne we're gonna
see Nightwing Gorilla Grodd if that was
him he looks a man
zing he looks so cool there are so many
awesome things with this and I mean I
don't know they may very well be that
this is an instance where it bridges the
gap between my inexperience with anime
and actually like bringing me into it
you know I'm not a hundred percent sure
I mean I saw like the the Iron Man anime
and like that sucked I did not like it
at all I don't think many people did
from what I gather uh but it looks like
it'll be really awesome and it looks
like it'll be interesting so I don't
know I mean for those of you guys who
are more knowledgeable about anime than
I am like I'm passing the ball to you I
mean I'm sure a lot of you guys out
there who watch these uh watch my videos
are probably familiar with anime I know
my editor Gordon is say what's up Gordon
you gotta chime in dude you got to say
something you got to be like what's up
guys I don't know so yeah anime is kind
of SuperDuper my thing giant robots
waifu's judges so yeah if you've ever
seen any sort of weird anime reference
in any of Rob's videos most likely
because of me alright with that out of
the way back to rob anyway I know a lot
of you guys are really familiar with
that kind of stuff but post something
down below like you know let me know
what you guys think I mean you know if
like correct my knowledge on anime too
and if you can like if it's something
you guys want to do like give me a place
to start I'm sure Gordon will just start
sending me all these different links
like start here and here and here and
here and here again my experience on
anime is based in Dragonball that's it
like that's the only real anime I ever
watched
I know video Berk how much story and try
to get me into I can't even water it was
call anymore it's some anime where like
giant robots are eating people or
something like that I don't know it's it
was weird and I was like okay this is
this is strange and like I didn't really
have a desire to watch it just because I
don't really care about robots eating
people but he tried to get me to watch
that and then there were a couple others
that he was trying to get me to watch
and I saw a few of them but I thought it
was just it was so far out there that I
couldn't get into it so like 5 sitting a
little more toned down like don't send
me into the deep end don't be like hey
Rob like to start with this and it's
like some super weird thing but give me
something that that seems to be familiar
you know something that I can grasp on a
basic level for my part I'm coming from
like Western animation western cartoons
to be all animations or cartoons I don't
know if like the Japanese community
considers anime to be cartoons I can
certainly be cartoons because we're
animations so I mean anything animated
as a cartoon to me but but let me know I
mean
like zimy some stuff like like send me
some links to stuff and let me know what
you guys think about the whole thing
again I'm pretty excited I mean you know
the Joker's what I'm most excited about
because we get to see a sword fight
between Batman and the Joker and I am
hyped about that like that's kind of the
cool thing it seems like it gives the
Joker so much more character like that's
that's really what I'm harping on here
because the Joker I think is one of the
coolest characters who was never really
developed like I mean he was just there
and he was the goofy guy then he would
do some goofy things but at the end of
the day that's all the Joker ever was
he's just a goofy guy who does goofy
things and sometimes it's cool
sometimes it's dark but that's really
about it like when you get down to it
he's never really been expanded on or
explored all that much in DC Comics is
just what's the Joker gonna do this time
you know and that's it that's why I love
the new 52 run of Batman because it
explores so much that stuff for the
Joker but it looks like the Joker is
gonna get so much development in this
and I'm really hyped like I'm really
really excited like man a sword fight
between Batman and the Joker looks like
it'll be awesome again like it looks
like it's gonna be like a high lead you
know dramatized Germanna ties I don't
have your handset but it's gonna be
highly dramatic which I'm kind of
interested in probably a lot of talking
to be honest but again I'm kind of down
with that kind of stuff I kind of like a
lot of dialogue that builds character
and things like that because you know it
goes towards the fact that when
something happens to that character it
matters like for example when it came to
the Dragon Ball series like when when
Vegeta finally takes his hat off to Goku
in the Buu saga and it's just like yeah
man you're better than me always like
dude this is like 200 and something
episodes in the making like I'm so happy
to see this who is it was so awesome to
see I kind of think the G does better
than Goku to be honest I'm a Vegeta
fanboy don't know what to tell you but
uh but I don't know I mean back to the
topic at hand I do think it's gonna be
awesome
I think therefore a lot of people like
myself who are sort of in this no-man's
land or they don't really know where to
start with anime they don't really know
how to get into it they don't even
really know much about the anime culture
I think this could be like an amazing
bridge point because for a person who's
coming from comic books and especially
with someone as high-profile as Batman
throwing a man to an anime style movie
of sorts and then taking all the
characters that were familiar with
reworking them and making them probably
more intriguing than they are right now
and a lot of the animated forms that
exist I think it's gonna be awesome
because when you look at the existing DC
Animated universe as awesome as it is
with stuff like you know the Dark Knight
Returns and like flashpoint again a lot
of that's basically established on how
we see the characters right now by how
do you see the Joker how you see the
/ how you see Aquaman Wonder Woman
Batman Superman how do you see those
characters at the moment is how those
stories are done because they're based
on existing comic book stories whereas
as far as I'm aware there's really no
you know manga for like Batman I mean
grabbing that whole concept grabbing
that character and throwing him into the
anime style and doing sort of a tip of
the nod to the Batman mythos while at
the same time adapting it to the anime
culture that people are familiar with I
think would be cool then I think it'll
be interesting and I think it'll come
out to be something pretty stellar but
in the event it's kind of my thoughts on
this let me know what you guys think
down in the in the comment section if
you are new here to come this explain
make sure you guys at the sub button to
become part of the Rob pork you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]